hey everyone I'm Devin and I'm Jared and
have you ever noticed you can tell a lot
about a person by what they choose to
eat Jared what did you know that Hitler
had a sweet tooth I don't really think
much about the other nonsense did you
also know that Audrey Hepburn was
addicted to carve everyone is addicted
to carbs and do you know that one of
helen keller's favorite food was a salad
no one's favorite food is a salad I know
it's [ __ ] up on this show Jared and I
are gonna recreate the recipes left
behind by our most talked-about
historical figures and attempt to spill
the tea on their personal lives
I bring the stories Jared does the
cooking because he's beautiful
and he can actually follow directions
girl get out but it's true some of these
recipes are gonna be delicious some of
them are gonna be terrible but I promise
you all of them tell an entertaining
tale Jared has no idea what these
recipes are very excited to see how this
goes
let's dive in so this week we're
starting with Marilyn Monroe stuffing
recipe which the New York Times deems as
handsome balanced and delicious funnily
enough those are the three words I used
to describe Jared here you've never
called me any of those things to my face
this recipe is especially noteworthy
because it was penned on some stationery
from a title insurance company in San
Francisco do you think your follow this
I literally can't read any of these
words why is it so faded because its
history Jared because it's [ __ ]
history this recipe was written between
1955 and 1956 around the same time
Marilyn Monroe met and married
playwright Arthur Miller which brings us
to the scandal that this stuffing is
going to unstuff for us who do we think
was Marilyn's true love this slip of
paper holds the answer to our question
at all so details that we have to buy
turkey livers you did not tell me that
we have to buy turkey livers or hearts I
refuse to touch a heart on this show you
didn't tell me that what do we get into
this Jared this recipe holds the truth
let's go so this recipe includes 11
different ingredients plus salt pepper
and five different herbs and spices
usual suspects but before we get all of
that it's time for our first key bit
our first boy team it it's like a tidbit
of information but it's
I hate how excited you are about this
keep at number one okay we'll just leave
this here I guess so Marilyn Monroe is
actually married to Joe DiMaggio in 1954
in the San Francisco City Hall hey
Jarrett Oh San Francisco yeah the
[ __ ] wood she wrote the recipe so the
recipe was actually discovered in her
New York apartment that she shared with
Arthur Miller I just think it's
interesting that it's written down on
stationery from a title insurance
company from San Francisco walnuts it's
not the only nut we need hey celery why
is it so wet
pine nuts because we did need more than
just one type of nut and he made it
weird no garlic
raisins oh look cheese parmesan I can
grate it myself I'll be so nice yes
we're gonna buy grated no okay do you
want this to taste good yeah can you
shred it yourself
it's way better right dog bread bread
bread bread let's get this man a snack
what a for it ready to dip your bread
and some California grown chicken livers
those are very close to my face it's
gonna take these away from you way over
here we [ __ ] yeah now that we're back
in the kitchen it's time for tea bit
number two bit number two cooking tip
number one is to probably remove any
rings and/or loose jewelry you can end
up in our food okay time for tea bit
number two did you know that Marilyn
Monroe wrote poetry I have told you so
many times I don't know anything about
her so no I didn't know that did and it
was actually very very good Marilyn if
you can hear me girl I just want to let
you know that your poetry is really good
and don't listen to a thing that Arthur
Miller has to say
first of all that drama is just not like
vibing with our set right now second of
all what did Arthur Miller say though
well I'll talk about that later but
first let's get to the ingredients well
so we had the eggs boiling first what
we're gonna want to do is prep these
fresh ingredients we have a lot of
chopping to do which I'm gonna delegate
to you we're gonna need four stalks of
celery and I would cut it however finely
you'd want to chop them it says four
celery stalks
but like this is a smaller stock than
this so I would just chop it up to do
five it's not not following the recipe
so the thing about cooking is that the
ingredient ratios don't make a
difference to whether the dish is
actually going to work or not so don't
overthink your celery game let me tell
you something about Marilyn Monroe now
that you mentioned overthinking oh okay
good segue when she first got into the
relationship with Arthur Miller she was
really overthinking it in fact she wrote
a lot of poetry about it girl was in
love like very much so that said this is
still Joe DiMaggio's recipes the sheer
fact that she took a recipe from San
Francisco that was like a Bay Area
recipe for Joe DiMaggio back to her
apartment in New York City that she
shared with Arthur Miller is a lot
I am wielding this knife and I I think I
was keeping an eye on it I mean like it
makes sense though that if she had a
recipe that she was really proud of that
she would just keep using it true but
like you'd think she'd be like okay I'm
not married to Joe DiMaggio anymore I
can add garlic that I will say yeah all
right I chopped celery look at me you
did a great job let's chop parsley we
need like two whole cups of it as I'm
just handling these nuts I'm gonna toast
these now you'll know when it's done
just because you'll smell it see it can
you smell that oh yes toasty that's when
you know it's done tell me more about
Joe DiMaggio I mean other than I love
the sound of his name I don't really
know anything about him he was a Yankee
slicker absolutely but I feels like that
he kind of really fell in love what was
that about love just kidding I'm so gay
it feels like from everything I've read
about Joe DiMaggio that he really fell
in love with like at home Marilyn she
you know really starting to blow up in
her stardom especially for being like a
sex symbol he had a problem with it I'm
not checking my phone I'm just checking
the timer for these eggs which I didn't
even set
so they're probably done do you think it
should be smaller because this is like
this is chopped
this is Devon's chopped I'm insulted do
you want to peel these eggs look at how
nicely this is chopped honestly I can't
say a damn thing negative about that
that looks great thank you okay you're
gonna want to do 1 cup of grated
Parmesan cheese okay and in the meantime
I will cut up the onion I can already
feel this onion try to move a crime
that's really [ __ ] up we should soak
this bread mmm okay here we go
this feels really wrong I'm not even
doing it touch it so this has to go for
15 minutes and then we have to boil the
chicken livers that's time we don't have
to until the water's boiling we can wait
we can do the other meat first
so as we chop and saute and work with
this raw meat I want to talk about
Arthur Miller
there was no segue there did you know
that he went to University of Michigan
go blue I didn't are you oh you went to
university of vision I did did you know
that yo girl performed in the crucible
as goody Proctor on her senior year what
does that have to do with this it really
doesn't have anything to do with it it's
not a team it it's just a fun little
factoid about mm-hmm honestly Jarrod I
used to be such a huge fan of Arthur
Miller because of University of Michigan
but doing all this research about
Marilyn Monroe I am low-key changing my
mind about him Charlie after Marilyn
Monroe broke up with Joe DiMaggio she
met Arthur Miller and when I say she
fell hard
the [ __ ] fell hard that happiness and
the marriage didn't last long
it never does in 1956 the couple moved
to England and shortly after that
Marilyn found a diary entry of Arthur
Miller's where he said that he was
embarrassed by her and was disappointed
to take her around his friend sue that's
[ __ ] up it's so [ __ ] up but also
what was she doing its diary up timer
our bread is ready something tells me
that you're really excited to tear the
spread apart
I'm gonna start putting this together
love it we're done ready for the meets
yep
in you go fat and all I'm sure Marilyn
would have liked arranged that but I
don't want to do that we've saved the
best for last
[Laughter]
Darion if Marilyn can work with chicken
livers so can we
okay no this is for Marilyn I hate
making direct eye contact with it do you
I'm a biohazard now put a wooden spoon
now that these livers have given us
enough trouble it's time to cut them out
it's so bulbous really upset I'm not
upset I'm just stressed every moment of
my life moving forward I'll think of
your strength in this moment it's
nothing like Marilyn Monroe strength
because after her marriage and did with
Arthur Miller she actually committed
herself to a psych ward oh [ __ ] is that
bad well she committed herself cuz she
was an insomniac and she just needed
some rest but then they held her against
her will for three days and she couldn't
even she wasn't even allowed a phone
call and that [ __ ] died how is that even
like legal let's put all together I'm
getting tired of standing here with you
you're never tired of staying at me I'm
tired of standing that's a lie
it's smells so good it's so green it is
very appealing visually wait should we
put an M in it put this here yeah yeah
that's not gonna translate through
baking well still no that was for you
for you girl okay let's put this in the
oven let's get it done wait taystee is
actually very very busy today so we
don't have access to their ovens so can
we go to your house yeah I guess so
let's go
my I like kitchens not ready to be
inside how people inside it's kind of
[Laughter]
it's really sunny out here in the real
world who your phone dip my keys are at
the office no unfortunately we don't
have enough time to go back to Busbee to
get your keys so we're just gonna go to
a neighbor's don't don't go in the oven
by stuffing see you in an hour
[Music]
Hey look at that em that you made that's
great you didn't anticipate how hard it
would be to get a hot thing back to the
office so I hope this blankets like
rated for this temperature or I'll just
get a bunch of melted polyester on my
lap what a goddamn journey this has been
today it certainly has been before we
dig in no yep I want it now I have our
last and final team it okay fine what is
it
so after Marilyn Rowe was committed and
held against her will to psych ward
there was only one person who could get
her out and that person was Joe DiMaggio
what and they kind of rekindled some
sort of romance and when she committed
herself to the psych ward he was keeping
tabs on her and he broke her out how
cute is that that's pretty sweet
rumor has it that they were gonna get
remarried but she died shortly
thereafter what I know that's the second
let's again I dedicate this dish we made
to Marilyn it's to Marilyn so yourself
I'm not your mom what so whether she
loved Joe DiMaggio Arthur Miller the
world may never know but she loved to
cook which I didn't know before I
started doing this research for this
episode I didn't know that she loved any
of those things before I was here
yesterday full disclosure I'm not really
a stuffing fan but I really do love the
taste and the texture of this stuffy
this is actually really good America
there's a lot of rich flavors yeah like
the chicken livers are really deep nudie
flavor apartment Jean is a really like
musky right it tastes romantic I mean I
suspect that this might be something
that used to impress every man that
would work on me I think I would
definitely make this recipe again just
because it makes me feel closer to
Marilyn I mean she tasted exactly this
we're sharing a mouth filled with
Marilyn Monroe right now that's really
cool I'm actually very like excited
about this and like definitely want to
do this with other people throughout
history I think this is like a really
fun thing to do those key bits aren't
too bad are they there whatever so we
got rare this with people around the
office
yeah oh my mom wait surely raisins
that's a cool time I can see her like
just cleaned out and found the table and
being like so proud of herself I made
this for my boyfriend I think he would
be really into it maybe break you out of
a mental institution a couple years down
the line if you do I think so
[ __ ] yes a really good job and the
chicken livers they don't suck oh are
you serious oh my god